Hallo, guten Tag. Nehmen Sie bitte Platz.
Dankeschön, ja.
Ja, mein Name ist Tezan. Ich bin der zuständige Arzt auf dieser Station.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen dieses Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Zunächst werde ich Ihnen ein paar Fragen stellen.
Ich werde jetzt Ihre ein paar Fragen stellen.
Danach können Sie mir Ihre aktuelle Beziehung stellen.
Dann sehen Sie damit ein paar Stande.
Oh, machen Sie nicht so schnell.
Langsamer.
Gut, also mein Name ist Paul Bach.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihren Vor- und Nachdamen langsam ein Buch stabilieren?
Ja, der Vorname ist Paul P. A. U. L.
Ganz gut. Und Bach ist auch ganz kurz. B. A. C. H.
Herr Bach, wie alt sind Sie und wann genau sind Sie geboren?
Ich bin noch 51 Jahre alt.
51.
Und wann genau sind Sie geboren?
Am 8. 04.74.
Das ist ein sehr guter Punkt.
Am 8. 04.1900.
1974.
74.
Wie groß sind Sie und wie viel wegen Sie, Herr Bach?
Ich bin 1,81 m und wiege so um die 75 kg.
75 kg.
75.
Nicht 70, 75.
75, okay.
Herr Bach, welche Beswerde haben Sie?
Was führt Sie zu uns heute?
Ja, wissen Sie, ich habe so komischen Husten.
Es war heute Morgen, hat es schon angefangen.
Dass ich zwischendurch das Gefühl habe, ich kriege überhaupt gar keine Luft mehr.
Das wird dann irgendwann wieder besser.
Aber es ist richtig beängstigend.
Ich muss husten und habe dann das Gefühl, ich kriege gar keine Luft mehr.
Und nach einer Weile ist es dann wieder weg.
Aber diese Zeit, bis es wieder weggeht, ist ganz beängstigend.
Das ist ganz unangenehm.
Ja, ich verstehe Sie, Herr Bach.
Ich verstehe, Ihr Husten hat flüssig angefangen, richtig?
Das hat ziemlich plötzlich angefangen.
Also, ja, ich habe schon seit ein paar Wochen so ein bisschen husten.
Ich habe schon seit ein paar Wochen so ein bisschen husten.
Aber dass ich das Gefühl habe, keine Luft zu kriegen, ist ganz neu.
Okay, seit zwei Wochen?
Ja, seit zwei Wochen, ich habe jetzt Winter, da sind alle erkältet.
Okay, vor zwei oder drei Wochen hatten Sie Erkältung, oder?
Ja, ich huste immer schon so ein bisschen, ja.
Okay, hatten Sie vor zwei Wochen Feber?
Ja, ich habe schon seit ein paar Wochen Feber.
Vor zwei Wochen Feber?
Nein, nein, Feber hatte ich nicht.
Nur Erkältung, oder?
Ja, ich huste halt so ein bisschen, ja.
Und heute haben Sie auch Atemnot.
Ja, heute ist es neu dazugekommen, dass ich mit einmal so dieses Gefühl habe,
dass ich keine Luft kriege.
Okay, können Sie bitte Ihren Husten beschreiben,
wie ist das mit Auswurf oder...
Das passiert überhaupt gar nichts.
Drucken an Husten, ja.
Und Ihre Husten ist nicht dauerhaft,
ab und zu.
Und auch Ihr Atemnot ist auch dauerhaft.
Nein, zum Glück nicht, das würde uns ja verrückt werden, wenn das ständig wäre.
Zwischendurch geht das weg.
Ich muss zwar immer mal wieder ein bisschen husten,
aber diese komischen Anfälle, das ist nicht ständig zum Glück.
Okay, Ihr hustet nicht wie Atake?
Ja, so kann man das sagen.
Und habt ihr uns bemerkt, gibt es einen Auslöser?
Ich wüsste jetzt nicht so richtig.
Ich habe nichts Besonderes gegessen oder getrunken, oder...
Ich weiß nicht.
Aber es gibt bestimmte Situationen,
dass Ihre Beschwerden verstärken oder verlinden,
haben Sie etwas bemerkt?
Ja, möglicherweise ist Kälte so ein bisschen,
dass das schlecht ist.
Ich weiß es gar nicht, aber ich habe jetzt nicht so einen direkten Zusammenhang gesehen.
Oder ist das abhängig von der Belastung?
Nein, also ich habe jetzt ja heute nicht mehr gemacht als sonst.
Ich habe mich jetzt nicht übermäßig angestrengt oder so.
Okay, und können Sie gut schlafen, wie können wir husten?
Na ja, also wenn ich gerade husten muss,
kann ich nicht gut schlafen, aber normalerweise kann ich gut schlafen.
Ja, verstehe.
Haben Sie momentan feber, Herr Bach?
Ich habe nicht gemessen, aber ich fühle mich eigentlich überhaupt nicht fieberig.
Sie fühlen sich nicht fieberig?
Nee, gar nicht.
Okay, haben Sie noch weitere Beschwerden, außer husten und atemnot?
Na ja, das ist langfristig.
Schmerzen? Schmerzen habe ich nicht, nein.
Schmerzen, keine Schmerzen.
Oder haben Sie irgendwo Schmerzen?
Nein, nein, das tut eigentlich ja nicht weh,
sondern es ist nur, dass man so Angst bekommt.
Ja, und können Sie bitte Ihre Atemnot,
Ihre Atemnot beschreiben, ist das beim Einatmen
oder beim Ausatmen oder egal?
Kann ich gar nicht so genau sagen, ich habe das Gefühl,
ich kann mit einmal nicht mehr atmen, ja so.
Nicht einatmen.
Herr Bach, hatten Sie früher eigentlich Beschwerden
oder ist das zum ersten Mal aufgetreten?
Also solche komischen Aussetzer, das habe ich zum ersten Mal.
Zum ersten Mal.
Ja, deswegen bin ich ja auch so erschrocken, wenn ich das schon kennen würde.
Aber ich kann es mir gar nicht vorstellen.
Ich bin ja jetzt schon ein bester Alter,
also da hat man ja nichts Neues eigentlich.
Momentan fühlen Sie sich, ja, können Sie momentan
gut Luft bekommen?
Im Augenblick ja, aber das kann sein, dass es in ein paar Minuten
wieder losgeht, dass ich dann keine Luft kriege.
Okay, es dauert ein paar Minuten.
Ja, das dauert schon, also es erscheint,
das ist wie eine Ewigkeit, aber es sind dann tatsächlich so
etwas über 10 Minuten oder so und dann ist es wieder gut.
Okay, wenn Sie momentan brauchen, können wir
dieses Gespräch unterbrechen und kann ich Ihnen
Luft geben?
Im Augenblick geht es ja.
Können Sie bitte wieder holen?
Im Augenblick geht es mir ja gut.
Okay, können wir weitermachen?
Ja, ja klar.
Okay, haben Sie bei diesem Zeitraum, ich meine seit 2 oder 3 Wochen,
Ihren Hausarzt oder andere Erste aufgesucht?
Nein, wegen bisschen Husten gehe ich ja nicht zum Arzt.
Oder haben Sie irgendein Werkes Medikament wegen
Ihrer Schmerzen angenommen?
Nein, ich habe also nicht mal irgendwie Hustensacht
oder sowas genommen. Also ich habe mal einen Bongbong
gelutscht vielleicht, ja damit ich nicht so
husten muss, aber sonst habe ich nichts gemacht.
Haben Sie auch Altschmerzen? Hatten Sie oder momentan haben Sie
Altschmerzen?
Kopfschmerzen habe ich eigentlich nicht.
Kopfschmerzen habe ich auch nicht, ne?
Okay, Sie haben keine Schmerzen.
Ne, ne, eigentlich nicht.
Und Sie haben keinen Ausrüster bemerkt,
dass Ihre Beschwerden beginnt.
Ich kann es mir nicht erklären. Also ich kann nicht sagen,
dass ich nicht so gut bin, aber damit hat es angefangen oder so.
Ja Herr Bach, haben Sie Herzrausen, Herzklopfen?
Also ich vielleicht, dass man so ein bisschen Herzklopfen,
wenn das gerade so mit der Luftnot ist,
dass man dann vielleicht so denkt, oh, jetzt merke ich mein Herz,
aber eigentlich klopft es ganz normal sonst.
Okay.
Nein, nein, nein, also ich habe kein Fieber und die Schütze auch nicht übermäßig.
Ne, zum Glück nicht.
Nein.
Herr Bach, haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder beim Stuhlgang?
Gibt es Veränderung in letzter Zeit?
Ja, also ich habe dauerhaft eigentlich so ein Reizdarm-Syndrom.
Wenn ich Stress habe, dann reagiere ich mit Durchfall
und dann habe ich auch ein bisschen Bauchschmerzen.
Aber wie gesagt, das ist nur, wenn es bei der Arbeit oder so
gerade mal sehr stressig ist.
Ja, verstehe.
Wie lange haben Sie Reizdarm-Syndrom?
Schon lange eigentlich, schon seit Jahren.
Ich nehme da jetzt so ein Medikament und damit ist das eigentlich ganz gut.
Verstehe.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit ab oder zu genommen, Herr Bach?
Ne, mein Gewicht ist eigentlich immer gleich.
Also ich wiege mich jetzt auch nicht ständig,
aber ich merke, dass man immer merkt,
ob die rutschen oder nicht.
Verstehe.
Herr Bach,
wie haben Sie das Reizdarm-Syndrom,
andere krönliche Erkrankungen,
wie Bluthochdruck, Schukakrankheit oder andere?
Zum Glück nicht.
Aber eine Sache, das ist aber schon lange her,
aber das wird mir ja nie so richtig los.
Ich hatte eine Hepatitis, also eine Hepatitis A.
Ja, das ist zehn Jahre her.
Da hatte ich einen langen Aussatzaufenthalt
und da habe ich mir das eingefangen.
Und da, so, ja, das ist halt immer noch irgendwie so schwebend.
Ja, Herr Bach,
wann war das vor zehn Jahren?
Das ist zehn Jahre her, ja, genau.
Vor zehn Jahren, nicht im Alter von zehn Jahren.
Nein, nein, vor zehn Jahren.
Okay.
Wo dann sich schon einmal operiert, Herr Bach?
Na ja, so in der Kindheit,
sehr blind am Raus und die Mann denn Raus, ja, das ist mal gemacht worden,
aber sonst nichts größeres, irgendwie in letzter Zeit.
Okay. Waren diese Operationalen komplikant schon los, oder?
Ich kann mich da nicht mehr gut dran erinnern,
aber wenn da irgendetwas Besonderes gewesen wäre, das wüsste ich.
Und wann war es, wie alt war sie, erinnern sie sich daran?
Also, bei der Mandeloperation, da war ich gerade in der Schule,
da war ich so sieben Jahre alt.
Sieben, okay.
Und beim blinden, ja, da habe ich schon studiert,
also da war ich so 20 ungefähr.
Wahnsinn, okay.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf Medikamente ein, Herr Bach?
Ja, eben dieses Zeug gegen den Reizdarm, das nehme ich bei Bedarf.
Wenn ich da Probleme habe, dann nehme ich das.
Ja, welche Medikamente, wie sind Sie?
Das heißt Kijimia.
Ich habe ihn nicht verstanden können.
Kijimia.
Und welche Röhrung wissen Sie?
Oh, keine Ahnung, da nimmt man so eine Kapsel, also ich kann nicht sagen, wie viel das ist.
Okay, Kapsel und bei Bedarf.
Hab ich was?
Nicht, dass ich wüsste.
Als Kind hatte ich mal ein bisschen Probleme, da hatten wir eine Katze
und da fing meine Haut an zu jucken, das ist jetzt immer Wachsender, Alter.
Ja, gut, jetzt haben wir auch keine Katze mehr, aber das haben wir nicht.
Ja, früher hatten sie Katzehade allergeben.
Ja, genau, aber das hat sich irgendwie verwachsen, das ist nicht mehr.
Okay, wie äußert es sich?
Mit Juckern, die Haut hat genügt.
Okay, okay, okay, Juckern.
Okay, haben Sie auch Unfertilikaten?
Ja, so lange ich nicht gerade Stress zusätzlich habe, kann ich eigentlich alles vertragen, ja.
Also ich bin jetzt nicht gerade so ein Freund von ganz schweren Essen, also wegen des Darmes,
aber eigentlich kann ich alles vertragen.
Okay.
Ich mag halt nicht alles, aber ich vertrage alles.
Ja, vielleicht auch, sehr herrbach.
Nee, zum Glück nicht, also das habe ich zum Glück nie angefangen.
Sehr gut, ich kürze natürlich Ihnen.
Nehmen Sie Alkoholschuhe sich?
Alkoholschuhe, ja, ich trinke sehr gerne mein Glas Rotwein, also meistens am Wochenende, so ein, zwei Gläser, ja.
Ein... nur am Wochenende?
Eigentlich nur am Wochenende, ja, oder wenn es mal etwas zum Feiern gibt zwischen Gerügen auch, ja.
Okay, okay, wocheneinander oder Feiern oder Treffen.
Ich habe eine Routine Frage, Herr Bach.
Haben Sie Kontakt mit dem Drogen?
Mit Drogen?
Ne, also da habe ich eigentlich immer die Finger davon gelassen.
Was haben Sie? Hab ich nicht verstanden?
Hab ich nie genommen.
Sehr gut.
Treiben Sie Sport?
Na, so nicht so wirklich, also ich gehe im Sommer ganz gerne mal schwimmen und dann fahre ich auch Fahrrad.
Jetzt im Winter ist es schon ein bisschen schwieriger.
Manchmal gehe ich da auch in die Schwimmballe, aber nicht so regelmäßig.
Okay, im Winter können wir kaum Sport, aber im Sommer...
Da schon ein bisschen mehr, ja.
Okay, okay, vielleicht okay.
Insbesondere wenn ich schwimme und Fahrrad fahre.
Mhm.
Herr Bach, sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Gegen Kinderkrankheiten, Gegen Grippe...
Kinderkrankheiten sind schon lange her, ja.
Also gegen Corona bin ich damals also dreimal geimpft worden.
Gegen Corona dreimal?
Mhm.
Und gegen Grippe im Funk?
Na, habe ich dieses Jahr nicht gemacht, aber sonst habe ich das hin und wieder mal gemacht, ja.
Okay, dieses Jahr nicht?
Nee, dieses Jahr nicht.
Sind Sie in letzter Zeit im Ausland gewesen, Herr Bach?
Nee, im Ausland war ich nicht.
Was machen Sie beruflich, Herr Bach?
Ich arbeite im IT-Bereich.
Im IT-Bereich?
Im IT-Bereich. Also so Computer.
Computer?
Im IT-Bereich.
Okay, Entschuldigung, ich habe ja nicht verstanden, okay, aber momentan okay.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet, ja.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Nee, leider noch nicht.
Sie hatten gesagt, dass Sie Reisdamm Sandrum hat
und wegen der Stress haben Sie insbesondere Probleme.
Ja, haben Sie viel Stress in Ihrem Leben oder bei der Arbeit?
Ja, bei der Arbeit ist es schon manchmal stressig, ja, doch.
Und ich glaube, Sie leben mit Ihrer Frau.
Bitte, was?
Ich glaube, ich vermute, Sie leben mit Ihrer Frau.
Ja, das ist schon besser so, ja, genau.
Und seit Neuestem haben wir auch noch ein Hund, ja.
Und Hund?
Keine Katze, okay.
Keine Katze, ein Hund, ja.
Herr Bach, haben Sie bemerkt, gibt es Hautfarbeveränderungen,
insbesondere lieberen Farbeveränderungen wie billäulich?
Ich bin nicht aufgesahlen, ne?
Und Sie hatten gesagt, dass Sie nicht Erbrochen haben?
Nee, ich habe nicht.
Ich meine, insbesondere nach dem Husten.
Nee, nee, also so war der Husten nicht.
Ich musste mich nicht übergeben.
Okay, Herr Bach, haben Sie noch weitere Beschwerden
oder möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Ich wüsste jetzt nicht, was ich Ihnen noch erzählen kann.
Ich habe Ihnen ja gesagt, dass ich solche Probleme habe,
dass ich eben diese Angstzustände habe, wenn ich keine Luft kriege, ja.
Ja, verstehe.
Und ich habe ja noch eine Frage.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Geschmuckverlust oder Geruchverlust?
Dass ich nichts mehr riechen kann.
Nein, das habe ich nicht.
Also meinen Sie, dass ich vielleicht Covid habe?
Neunmal habe ich einen Corona-Test gemacht.
Der war aber negativ.
Okay, sehr gut.
Okay, danke.
Ja, wir sind am Ende des Gesprächs.
Ich würde gerne zunächst die Körperleuchter untersuchen
und nach der Untersuchung Blut abnehmen und ein Grund Gambelt durchführen.
Nachdem ich alle Ergebnisse erraten habe, werde ich Sie sofort informieren, Herr Bach.
Okay, gut.
Legen Sie sich bitte auf die Liege zur Untersuchung.
Ja, ja, leg ich mich da mal hin.
Hat jemand noch zusätzliche Fragen?
Könnten Sie bitte wieder sagen in Ihre Medikamente,
was war der Kräbeln, Sie konnten nicht verstehen.
Kijimea.
Ja.
Ich weiß, Entschuldigung.
Es ist ein komisches Medikament,
das zurzeit in der Fernsehwerbung ständig angepriesen wird.
Wenn Sie deutsches Fernsehen gucken,
werden Sie ständig belästigt mit Kijimea plus,
was man in der Apotheke reikaufen kann.
Ja, meine Barge.
Ja, bitte.
Herr Bach, haben Kräten Ihren höchsten Anfälle
nachts, morgens oder den Ganztag, super auf?
Also das hat heute Morgen angefangen,
in der Nacht war das eigentlich nicht,
aber heute Morgen hat es angefangen
und ist dann tagsüber häufiger gewesen.
Ich habe Frage.
Bitte.
Seit wann leben Sie mit dem Hund zusammen?
Ja, den haben wir jetzt erst so ein knappen Monat.
Okay.
Hallo, guten Tag Frau Oberreisden.
Guten Tag.
Ich habe heute einen neuen Patientin aufgenommen.
Ich würde gerne in Ihnen vorstellen,
Herr Tanze, kurz seit.
Ja, natürlich.
Er hat ihn gesehen.
Herr Bach, der 51-jährige Patient,
nämlich Herr Paul Bach,
ist 1 Meter 81 groß
und 75 Kilogramm schwer.
Herr Bach stellte sich heute bei uns
wegen seit heute Morgen bestehende
plötschlich aufgetretene,
attackartige Husten,
die es beschwerden.
Herr Bach berichtet,
dass er eigentlich seit 2-3 Wochen
weichte Husten hatte.
Aber heute hat es nicht so viel geworden.
Er hat keine Schmerzen,
insbesondere Bruce Schmerzen,
Torakage,
Furdeferneint,
Fiba, Schutelfrost, Pilexie,
Schutelfrost,
Furdeferneint,
seine Beschwerden
treten zum ersten Mal auf.
Was war denn der Grund,
warum hat er sich denn überhaupt vorgestellt?
Nur, weil er Husten hat?
Ich habe ihn nicht verstanden können.
Warum hat er sich vorgestellt?
Er hat plötschlich aufgetretene,
starke Husten und Dispineu-Einschuldigung.
Ich habe es vergessen zu sagen.
Seine Dispineu
ist nicht unabhängig von der Belastung
Hustenabhängig,
während er Husten hat
oder während er Huste hat er auch Dispineu.
Okay.
Wie gesagt, nicht Belastung abhängig.
Die vegetative Anamnese ist unaufgängig.
Bis auf
Reisam-Sambron-Bettingtä
Schulgang Veränderung, seit langem hat er.
Und Herzrasen hat er
oder klackte er über Herzrasen,
Tachikardie, während Dispineu.
Okay, ja.
Er leidet
an wie gesagt seit langem Reisam-Syndrom.
Und vor zehn Jahren hat er
Anhypatitis A-Erlitten.
Und bei dem Patient wurde
eine Tonselektomie im Alter von 7
Jahren durchgeführt.
Beide sind komplikationlos.
Er nimmt
bei Bedarf
Kijima
gegen Reisam-Syndrom an.
Er hat Katzeanergie,
aber seit langem hat er
kein Abenteuer.
Er hat keine Unfertigkeiten.
Er
hat Nukotinkonsum und
Drogenkonsum.
Er trinkt ein Glas Rotwein,
einmal oder zwei
Glas Proboche oder am Wochenende
oder bei Feiern.
Er treibt
im Winter Kainsport,
aber im Loma
oder in Schwimen oder Faradwaren.
Er ist vollständig geimpft.
Aber dieses Jahr hat er
keine Impfung gegen Influenza.
Die Reisam-Syndrom ist unaufgängig.
Er arbeitet
in der
IT-Bereich.
Er hat keine Kinder.
Er lebt mit seiner Frau
und mit
ihrem Hund.
So weit ich verstehe,
seit Kursen
hat sie Hund.
Okay, ja.
Ich hatte diese Frage nicht gestattet.
Frau Oberarsten,
die an einem nächsten Angaben
durchtun am ersten
auf eine allergische Asthma.
An allergischen Asthma
differenzial diagnostisch kommen
Petrusis oder
Stichwort.
Petrusis oder Pynomone
in Betracht.
Der Patient
hat plötsch
aufgetretenen.
Er wusste mit Dispynom
und er hat
seit Kursen
er hatte keine
Tier.
Er hatte keine Tier.
Er hatte seit Kursen
eher Hund.
Er hatte früher
auch Katze, Hare allerge.
Ich musste
und Geschichte
ausführlich
recherchieren.
Ich kann bei der Untersuchung
es nachholen.
Um meine Verdachtdiagnose
zu bestätigen,
werde ich den Patienten
körperlich untersuchen.
Was erwarten Sie?
Worauf achten Sie besonders bei der körperlichen Ordnung?
Ich werde darauf achten,
dass er
beim Ausatmen
Dispynöre hat.
Was nehmen wir es?
Expektorische?
Expektorische.
Ich werde darauf achten, ob er
ausatmen.
Ich werde natürlich
alle anderen
Parameter messen.
Und seine beide Lunge
und seine beide Lunge
auskultieren.
Es gibt auch andere
pathologische Geröche.
Ich werde natürlich
eine andere Lunge
auskultieren.
Was machen Sie mit den Augen?
Sie haben den Patienten gefragt,
ob er eine Blauverfärbung der Lippen bemerkt hat.
Liebte,
ob er Cyanose hat,
werde ich mit Sauerstoffsetzung.
Da sehen Sie es auch.
Was machen Sie mit den Augen?
Ich werde natürlich auch
eine andere Lunge machen.
Was sollte ich noch tun?
Was machen Sie mit den Augen?
Ich werde die Blutabnehmen
im Laborbechtümen tun.
Die große Blutbild-Parameter
wie CRP,
der ist
allergisch im Globalon-E.
Ja, sehr gut.
Im Globalon-E werde ich im Laborbechtümen lassen.
Und können wir auch
Pricktest durchführen?
Ja, sehr gut.
Was wäre dann noch eine weiterführende technische Untersuchung?
Ich werde es zunächst
durchführen.
Ich werde
insbesondere Pynomone
ausschließen.
Und wenn es gegebenenfalls
auch
Komputerisotomographie durchführen,
aber insbesondere
spyrometrie.
Das ist eine
seine Lungekapazität
richtig zu verstehen.
Wir brauchen
wir
die Prometrie.
Ja, sehr gut.
Dann halten Sie mich auf dem Laufenden über die Ergebnisse,
was dabei rauskommt, insbesondere bei der Auskultation.
Und
die Lungenfunktion, das werden wir wahrscheinlich nicht heute machen,
sondern irgendwann die nächsten Tage.
Aber auf alle Fälle
sprechen Sie mich nachher noch mal an, wenn wir alle Werte beieinander haben.
Ja?
Sprechen Sie mich nachher an,
wenn Sie mit dem Patienten alle Untersuchungen durchgeführt haben.
Ja, ich habe ja alle Untersuchungen
gemacht.
Wir fangen
mit der Therapie an.
Soll das ich Sie verdacht,
ich werde den Patienten
stationär aufnehmen.
Möglicherweise, ja.
Das ist abhängig von den Ergebnissen.
Ja, das stimmt.
Aber ich werde über
die Krankheit den Patienten informieren.
Es ist insbesondere über
Katzanergie und Hundanergie.
Ja, genau.
Haupttherapie ist abhängig von dem Hund.
Der Patient
soll eigentlich
diesen Hund
schicken.
Wenn er keinen Kontakt hat,
braucht er eigentlich keine Therapie.
Eigentlich nicht, genau.
Aber wenn er muss
diesen Hund besitzen,
können wir auch
Bronkodilatöre,
Sämtomatrische Behandlung beginnen.
Aber Haupttherapie ist abhängig
von den Auslösern.
Ja, haben Sie recht?
Ja, genau.
Ja, kommen wir zur Analyse.
Ein bisschen.
Was mir aufgefallen ist,
Sie sprechen ziemlich schnell
und ich kann Sie nicht immer super gut verstehen.
Also Sie sind,
ich muss sehr genau hinhören.
Ich überlege, woran es liegt.
Ich kann es nicht so richtig einordnen.
Ich glaube, Sie haben
nicht so viel Sprachmelodie in den Sätzen.
Sie sind immer auf einem Level.
Sie sagen immer das Gleiche.
Wenn Sie einen Satz anfangen
oder einen Satz beenden, das geht immer alles in einem Ton.
Man hört überhaupt keinen Unterschied.
Wir haben aber, das erleichtert uns das Verstehen.
Das Prinzip, das wir einen Satz haben,
wir fangen vorne an und dann beenden wir den Satz.
Dann kommt der Linker.
Dann geben wir die Stimme ein bisschen an
und gehen dann wieder runter.
Der Patient berichtet über zunehmende Luftnot
im Rahmen von Husten anfällen.
Dann kann man sie ein bisschen leichter verstehen.
Ist natürlich jetzt total schwer,
so etwas kurzfristig sich anzunüben.
Aber es würde auf die Dauer gesehen,
glaube ich, Ihnen helfen,
dass Sie ein bisschen leichter zu verstehen sind.
Also ein bisschen mehr Melodie rein in die Sprache.
Das muss man üben.
Man kann das ganz schnell machen.
Man kann das ganz gut üben,
wenn man Texte liest.
Wenn man Texte laut vorliest,
lese diese aus der Zeitung etwas vor
oder aus dem Kinderbuch oder aus dem Roman.
Und fangen Sie unten mit der Stimme an,
dann hat der Satz seinen Höhepunkt
und dann geht es wieder runter.
Wenn ich frage, dann machen Sie es eigentlich ein bisschen besser.
Die Lese war sprachlich okay.
Wie gesagt, manchmal ein bisschen schnell.
Und ganz selten mal habe ich nachgefragt.
Ich habe gesagt, habe ich nicht verstanden.
Was war denn das?
Hab ich sie nicht verstanden?
Ach, Energien, genau.
Als Sie nach Allergien gefragt haben.
Was will er jetzt von mir?
Das Wort habe ich einfach nicht verstanden.
Allergien?
Wir sagen Allergie.
Ganz Deutsch.
Und das, was die Allergie auslöst,
ist das Allergien.
Und,
ja, was kann ich noch sagen?
Was mir aufgefallen ist bei der Anamnese,
Sie haben tatsächlich einen wichtigen Punkt vergessen.
Und das hat auch niemand nachgefragt.
Wir haben die Familie in Anamnese vergessen.
Eine Frage dazu.
Stimmt, ne? Ja.
Ja, ich habe jetzt bemerkt.
Ja.
Und, was ich witzig finde, das auch niemand sonst gefragt hat.
Ja, das wäre nämlich auch noch ein bisschen erhellend gewesen.
Weil die Mutter auch Asthma von Charlie hat.
Okay, gut.
Wir haben, ja, das also ein kleines inhaltliches Ding.
Aber, wie gesagt, sprachlich.
Lassen Sie sich Zeit.
Ja, lassen Sie sich Zeit mit Ihren Sätzen.
Dann kann man Sie ein bisschen besser verstehen.
Okay, danke.
Was haben wir noch?
Ja.
Beim Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch bin ich ja gleich am Anfang,
habe ich so ein bisschen nachgehackt,
weil Sie die Displöte gar nicht erwähnt haben.
Ja, das ist ja der entscheidende Punkt.
Der ist ja nicht wegen seines Hustens gekommen.
Den hat er ja schon seit drei Wochen.
Sondern der ist ja gekommen,
weil er mit einmal Luftnot hat.
Das kannte er nicht. Ja?
Und das ist das entscheidende Symptom.
Und das haben Sie am Anfang gar nicht erwähnt.
Ja? Ja.
Und deswegen habe ich als Oberärzt gesagt,
hey, wieso kommt denn der denn jetzt,
wenn er seit drei Wochen Husten hat?
Ja, der Husten ist schlimmer geworden.
Aber diese Attacken mit der Luftnot,
das ist ja das, was Angst macht.
Ja?
Wenn Sie mit einmal Ihre Luft nicht wieder loswerden,
das ist ja beim Arzt mal so.
Die kommt ja rein, aber sie kommt nicht wieder raus.
Ja.
Und das macht Panik.
Ja?
Und insofern denke ich mal,
das wäre schon ein wichtiger Punkt,
dass Sie das praktisch dann auf alle Fälle auch so übermitteln.
Und dann ist mir aufgefallen,
irgendwas haben Sie versucht zu erklären.
Ich überlege gerade, was war denn das?
War das jetzt beim Arzt?
Ich glaube beim Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch,
wenn Sie Ihr Schema verlassen,
wenn Sie frei formulieren müssen,
dann fangen Sie ein bisschen an zu schwimmen.
Ich kann Ihnen jetzt tatsächlich nicht mehr genau sagen,
was das für eine Aussage war.
Aber da haben Sie ein bisschen Probleme gehabt
mit der Formulierung.
Machen Sie sich praktisch denkbare Sachen klar,
was passieren kann.
Das ist zum Beispiel eine Untersuchung,
dass Sie eine Untersuchung beschreiben müssen.
Ja?
Dass Sie sagen, ich fühle bei den Patienten
eine Spirometrie-Untersuchung durch.
Und wenn Sie das den Patienten erklären,
dass Sie sich dann beispielsweise sagen,
ja, das ist eine aufwendige Untersuchung,
wo wir testen, wie gut Ihre Lunge funktioniert.
Es ist wichtig, dass Sie gut mitarbeiten.
Und eine Mitarbeiterin gibt Ihnen Kommandos
und dann müssen Sie einatmen, ausatmen
und die Luft anhalten, je nachdem.
Gut, dass man das erklärt,
dass Sie einfach sich sicher sind,
dass Sie richtige Sätze formulieren.
Ja?
Und das ist natürlich viel einfacher beim Fragestellen.
Klar, die Fragen haben Sie vorformuliert.
Da muss ich übrigens sagen, das war sehr schön.
Sie haben versucht, die Fragen zu variieren.
Sie haben den Patienten immer wieder mit Namen angesprochen,
was der natürlich nett findet.
Ja, Herr Bach, ist Ihnen aufgefallen,
das haben Sie bemerkt, ist Ihnen aufgefallen,
was auch immer.
Also das haben Sie sehr schön gemacht.
Ja?
Und man verlässt natürlich
dieses Katalogartige in dem Augenblick,
wo man seinen Bericht macht
und gerade wo man über,
ja, vielleicht über Spezialitäten spricht.
Genau, als Sie gesagt haben,
ja, der müsste sein Hund abschaffen.
Das wäre natürlich das Beste für ihn.
Ja, ist wahrscheinlich so, ja, genau.
Dabei haben Sie sich doch so über den Hund gefreut.
Ja, das ist so ein Leben.
Manchmal passt es nicht.
Ja, gut, das war natürlich richtig klar.
Asthma Brunchale hat er, das ist ein Düsseldorferfall.
Es ist ein relativ aktueller Düsseldorferfall
und relativ aktuell ist auch schon wieder,
der ist auch wieder zwei Jahre alt.
Aber, was ich erstaunlich finde,
der Fall hat eigentlich wenig Umfang.
Der hat nicht viel Information
und trotzdem kommt man aber eigentlich gut klar.
Man kann gut erkennen, worum es geht
und die entscheidenden Sachen müssen halt abgefragt werden.
Wie gesagt, passend sehr auf mit der Familie in einer Mese,
das ist wichtig.
Ja, manchmal vergesse ich leider.
Ja, ich weiß Sie,
Sie dürfen wahrscheinlich auch zur Prüfung keine Checkliste mitnehmen.
Sie haben bei der Prüfung keine Checkliste,
dass Sie sagen,
Ja, weiterer Prüfung,
das ist nicht so einfach.
Ich kann vergessen
und es gibt nur 20 Minuten.
Ja, Sie waren ein bisschen über das Land, aber nicht viel.
Ja, manchmal kann ich darauf nicht konzentrieren.
Aber machen Sie sich einfach klar
eine gewisse Reihenfolge, wobei es aber auch wichtig ist,
dass man diese Reihenfolge verlässt
in dem Augenblick, wo man die Informationen bekommt.
Und das ist natürlich eine Gemeinheit,
wenn der Prüfer so wie ich das jetzt auch gemacht hat.
Das ist ja ein sehr erwähnt mit dem Hund.
Das ist eine wichtige Information.
Die habe ich Ihnen aber so ein bisschen untergejubelt.
Die habe ich nicht an der richtigen Stelle gesagt,
wo man damit irgendwie rechnen würde.
Und das ist so,
dass man da aber auch merkt,
wie gut jemand mit der Sprache umgeht.
Hört der, was ich sage,
und ordnet er das in den richtigen Zusammenhang ein.
Das ist ja die entscheidende Geschichte,
wenn ich Sprache verstehe.
Nehme ich diese Information auf und ordne ich sie
dem richtigen Thema zu.
Nach dem Motto, Sie haben gesagt, Sie nehmen
das Kitschimea Plus, nehmen Sie noch etwas anderes.
Da haben Sie zugehört, was er vorher gesagt hat.
Und dann stellen Sie in dieser Stelle eben die Frage
nach weiteren Medikamenten.
Und das ist der entscheidende Punkt.
Zuhören, was der sagt, was da Ihnen eine Information gibt.
Und trotzdem den eigenen Fragenkatalog nicht vergessen.
Ja, ich würde sagen, ein bisschen ausbauffähig sind wir noch.
Kleinen bisschen Übung.
Und vor allen Dingen versuchen Sie mal für sich selber laut vorzulesen.
Mit der Sprachmodulation und genug Ruhe.
Das wäre, glaube ich, hilfreich zum Verstehen.
Haben Sie jemanden, der zuhört,
ein Partner, eine Partnerin, Kinder, wen auch immer,
den Sie was vorlesen können?
Eigentlich versuche ich, aber vielleicht brauche ich noch Zeit.
Ja, mir fällt gerade auf, was es sein kann.
Ich habe das schon vielen, vielen Kolleginnen und Kollegen von Ihnen gesagt.
Sie sprechen ziemlich hinten im Hals.
Sie merken, dass auch das ein bisschen heiser sind.
Holen Sie die Sprache nach vorne.
Da können Sie nicht dahin.
Da kann ich Sie nicht gut verstehen.
Wenn Sie da hinten im Hals reden.
Sie werden heiser und es strengt Sie an.
Sprechen Sie vorne mit dem Mund.
Normalerweise, seit einer Woche habe ich Heiserkeit.
Ja, wahrscheinlich die Gefahr nach.
Wegen Erkältung.
Ich weiß nicht, ich bin mir nicht sicher.
Vielleicht können wir widersprechen, nachdem ich wieder gesund bin.
Ja, das wäre, glaube ich, ganz gut, wenn wir noch einmal machen.
Das könnte sein, dass es diese leichte Heiserkeit ist,
die die Verständlichkeit auch ein bisschen leiden lässt.
Da sage ich jetzt mal, für heute gute Wässerung.
Ja, in allen schönen Abend.
Wir haben heute schon wieder Donnerstag.